alors que la police est pointée du doigt
depuis des mois amnesty international
publie un rapport qui accable la
profession selon les ong les
discriminations de la part de la police
sont omniprésentes en europe
et pour étayer ce rapport 12 pays
européens sont mentionnés une enquête
réalisée sous forme d'une interview par
téléphone et vidéos qui ont ensuite été
publiées sur les réseaux sociaux
selon les ong le confinement à décupler
le nombre d'interpellations violente les
violences policières et les inquiétudes
liées au racisme institutionnel ne sont
pas nouvelles mais la pandémie de kobe
19 et le contrôle coercitif de
l'application des mesures de confinement
qui en découlent ont révélé leur ampleur
amnesty épinglé la france notamment la
ville de nice qui a instauré un
couvre-feu plus long à certains
quartiers dont les habitants
appartiennent majoritairement à la
classe populaire et à des minorités
ethniques
il est également question du département
de la seine saint denis dans ce rapport
écouter
dans le département le plus pauvre de la
france métropolitaine la seine saint
denis où la majorité des habitants sont
noirs ou d'origine nord africaine
le nombre de contraventions pour
infraction au confinement a été trois
fois plus élevé que dans le reste du
pays
alors que selon les autorités locales le
respect des mesures de confinement était
semblable à ceux qu'ils étaient ailleurs
en france au royaume uni les fouilles
ont augmenté de 22 % entre mars et avril
pendant le confinement
selon le rapport la part de personnes
noires soumises à des fouilles a
progressé de près d'un tiers en belgique
les mesures de confinement ont eu un
impact disproportionné dans les
quartiers à forte population immigrée
lors de 36% des interpellations
la police aurait utilisé la force de
manière abusive et dans 21% des cas les
forces de l'ordre auraient insulté les
personnes interpellées en serbie les
autorités ont imposé un régime spécial
au centre d'hébergement accueillant
réfugiés et migrants avec des mesures
strictes de quarantaine avec une
surveillance 24 heures sur 24 par
l'armée le rapport mentionne aussi les
sdf dont des dizaines ont été verbalisés
en france en espagne et au royaume uni
pour ne pas avoir respecté les mesures
d'isolement à domicile alors si les
mesures de confinement n'ont pas été les
mêmes partout et pour tous amnesty
propose de son côté trois réformes
structurelles
la première en finir avec l'usagé
illégal de la force sa seconde roquette
mettre en place des outils statistiques
précis permettant d'étudier l'ampleur du
phénomène de discrimination
et enfin la troisième recommandation
pose la question de l'impunité des
forces de l'ordre